y
[Música]
100 días de la invasión rusa y ucrania
moscú concentra sus operaciones en
severodonezk y lysychansk las dos
últimas ciudades que faltan para que
controle toda la región de lugansk pero
el presidente ucraniano volodymyr se le
es que dice que su país será el vencedor
hablaremos con una de nuestras
corresponsales
turquía cambio de nombre y de ahora en
adelante se llamará turquía en todos los
idiomas el gobierno de reyerta y verdad
tomó la decisión para reivindicar los
valores culturales del país tenemos
reporte desde estambul
sudán conmemora tres años de la masacre
en la que el personal de seguridad a
todo por lo menos 128 personas en una
manifestación aunque el gobierno de
transición abrió una pesquisa no se ha
acusado todavía a los autores
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
yo soy maría clara calle y es un gusto
estar con ustedes
empezamos en ucrania hoy se cumplen 100
días desde que rusia comenzó la invasión
a ese país en este tiempo las tropas de
moscú han controlado el 20 por ciento
del territorio ucraniano según lo
reconoció el presidente de volodymyr
selenski y los civiles han padecido
duramente las consecuencias más de 4.200
personas han muerto y 14,8 millones
huyeron de sus hogares nuestra
corresponsal irene sabio ha cubierto la
guerra desde el día cero y a esta hora
hablamos con ella para conocer su
experiencia a propósito de esta fecha
irene bienvenida de nuevo además de
estar durante toda la guerra usted ha
viajado por el país cuéntenos cómo ha
cambiado ucrania según su visión
sí sí depende en realidad muchísimo de
la de la zona y vive en el oeste del
país yo diría que se ha continuado a
vivir con cierta normalidad aún en el
miedo de este miedo y esta atención y
también de algún bombardeo ocasional muy
distinta de la situación en el este del
país donde los combates siguen ustedes
lo mencionaban también hace poco ahí la
gente ha tenido que aprender a
sobrevivir con las sirenas con estos
cien días que han sido un sin parar
realmente de guerra de una guerra que
está continuando y también quería
mencionar el tema de las ciudades
ocupadas las ciudades ucranianas como
gerson de melitópol y la misma mar igual
ahí es una incógnita la situación de los
civiles tenemos pocas informaciones y
también hay que mencionar que la
perspectiva de cara al futuro es que
estas personas las personas que aún
quedan en estas ciudades en un futuro
estén viviendo
a unas zonas que serán parte de que
podrían ser parte de otro país por tanto
realmente la situación es muy distinta
según donde uno está en ucrania y en
este cubrimiento que historias son las
que más le han impactado
me han impactado muchísimas historias
que son difíciles de relatar en imágenes
como está cambiando la sociedad
ucraniana también el tema del
nacionalismo que será algo con lo que
ucrania tendrá que lidiar después de que
este conflicto se apague también me ha
impactado la calidez por ejemplo de las
de las personas en el este donde como
decía antes se siguen estos combates muy
intensos
estas personas que viven literalmente
bajo las bombas también lo he visto en
otros conflictos en por ejemplo en siria
he visto estas hartazgo de la guerra en
cierto momento que llega también a las
personas que se tienen que enfrentar a
esta realidad de forma cotidiana que
quieren seguir viviendo y que por tanto
encuentran formas
sobrellevar estas situaciones todas
estas historias son difíciles de relatar
a veces pero son parte de la realidad de
ucrania este momento hartazgo por parte
de la ciudadanía pero cuál es la
situación para los periodistas que tanto
riesgo corren los reporteros
bueno es una guerra convencional con lo
cual el riesgo existe nosotros andamos
por ahí con nuestros chalecos nuestros
cascos pero por supuesto al haber
artillería si uno acaba en medio de
disparos
de esta magnitud del peligro
evidentemente es muy alto por supuesto
se intenta medir todo se intenta medir
las rutas por lo que uno pasa el momento
del día la situación en el terreno pero
el escenario los escenarios son muy
cambiantes
todos los días hay novedades la línea
del frente se va moviendo constantemente
hay ciudades que pasan de mano
constantemente y de alguna forma se
refleja en el número de periodistas que
han fallecido hasta ahora que ya son más
de una veintena y como lo hemos
reportado en france24 ucrania sufre una
crisis de abastecimiento qué tan difícil
es conseguir los alimentos
es difícil conseguir muchas cosas los
alimentos pero también las medicinas los
ancianos por ejemplo sufren mucho por
esto porque algunos tienen patologías
previas y no es fácil para ellos sobre
todo estamos hablando de la zona del
este nuevamente es difícil abastecerse
de gasolina la gasolina es esencial para
el transporte y por tanto de alguna
forma influencia todo lo demás no
realmente todo en lo que significa
poder acceder a todo tipo de alimentos
de medicinas de de productos básicos
para la vida cotidiana y de nuevo aquí
con violencia antes los que están
sufriendo más son los que están en la
primera línea y por tanto las ciudades
más afectadas
del este y en particular de la zona del
donbass irene gracias por todas estas
historias y precisamente a propósito de
ucrania la crisis alimentaria está
afectando a otros países pues ucrania y
rusia son los mayores exportadores de
trigo ante el panorama el presidente
ruso alexandr lukashenko y lo que estaba
dispuesto a permitir el tránsito de
granos ucranianos para sacarlos por el
mar báltico a cambio el pide que belarús
pueda exportar sus propios productos la
propuesta se la hizo lukashenko antonio
gutiérrez secretario general de la onu
en una llamada que tuvieron hoy la
agencia oficial de noticias belta agregó
que el presidente pidió que los puertos
de alemania polonia y los estados
bálticos también permitan la exportación
de belarús sin embargo es difícil pues
el país es aliado de rusia
en parís se reunieron la presidenta de
la comisión europea úrsula von der leyen
y el presidente francés emmanuel majo
los líderes tendrán un almuerzo en el
elíseo para discutir la situación en
ucrania según la agenda presidencial con
der leyen agregó que hablarán de la
unión europea y su apoyo a los
ucranianos la reunión ocurre el mismo
día en que la unión europea adoptó
formalmente su sexto paquete de
sanciones contra rusia que incluye un
embargo progresivo sobre la mayor parte
de sus importaciones de petróleo ruso
en alemania la cámara baja del
parlamento aprobó un fondo especial de
107 mil millones de dólares para
fortalecer las fuerzas armadas del país
con 683 votos a favor y 96 en contra los
legisladores respaldaron la propuesta
del gobierno de gola scholz sin embargo
aún falta la aprobación de la cámara
alta- si pasa esa etapa los créditos
para modernizar las fuerzas armadas
alemanas no serán tenidos en cuenta con
respecto al techo de la deuda y
solamente la fuerza aérea recibirá 41
mil millones de euros previamente rusia
había advertido que la decisión de
alemania de invertir en un fondo para
dotar a sus fuerzas armadas suponía un
riesgo para la seguridad europea
y turquía cambió de nombre ahora el país
se llamará tur quien en todos los
idiomas según la informó el gobierno de
reyerta y verdú al a naciones unidas
este organismo internacional afirmó que
el cambio se realizará de inmediato
desde estambul nuestro corresponsal
adriana rocha nos explica por qué se
tomó esta decisión
turquía ya no existe a partir de hoy
mismo este viernes turquía pasa a
llamarse turquía que es lo mismo que
turquía pero en vez de un idioma en
extranjero será en turco así lo ha
confirmado naciones unidas- esta pasada
madrugada cuando ha confirmado que ha
recibido la carta del ministerio de
exteriores turco pidiendo precisamente
que se cambie el nombre oficial
internacional de charqui en inglés y en
francés o turquía en español y sólo en
turco turquía
este movimiento lleva tratándose en
turquía desde el pasado desde el pasado
diciembre cuando presente un corre septo
y perdona explicó que empezaba a turquía
esta iniciativa y viene sobre todo por
un gran motivo y es que en inglés
cherquis significa pavo que es lo que
comen los estadounidenses cuando
celebran uno de los días más populares
en su país que es el día de acción de
gracias además a
y en inglés significa algo así como
estúpido o tonto una persona que no
tiene mucho interés en lo que hacía hago
turquía que se quedó de distancia
completamente el gobierno turco asegura
que este cambio es para intentar darle
poder a los turcos para poder que
decidan ellos mismos cómo quieren que su
país sea llamado internacionalmente sin
embargo pasará lo que les pasa a muchos
otros países que han cambiado el nombre
hace poco como la república checa- en
2016 o holanda en 2020 a partir de
entonces holanda pasó a llamarse
solamente países bajos y la república
checa- chequia sin embargo
internacionalmente se sigue amando igual
a estos países turquía quiere hacer el
mismo camino veremos en el futuro los
ciudadanos del mundo pasan a llamarle de
turquía turquía turquía o en otros
idiomas a solamente turquía en noticias
de áfrica sudán se prepara para
conmemorar el tercer aniversario de la
masacre del 3 de junio mientras tanto
muchas de las familias de las víctimas y
los propios sobrevivientes siguen
buscando justicia según diversos
informes ese día murieron 128
manifestantes a manos del personal de
seguridad aunque el gobierno de
transición puso en marcha una
investigación no se ha acusado a los
autores de las atrocidades a
continuación veamos un informe que
repasa los acontecimientos y explica por
qué la justicia sigue siendo
inalcanzable para quienes apoyan la
revolución sudanesa
sudán un estado frágil al borde de la
crisis y donde la gente sigue clamando
por justicia tres años después de una de
sus masacres más mortíferas 3 de junio
de 2019 centro de jartúm habían pasado
dos meses desde que el longevo dictador
omar al-bashir había sido derrocado como
presidente en un golpe de estado un
consejo militar de transición asumió el
poder pero los manifestantes de esta
sentada pedían un retorno incondicional
al gobierno civil
[Música]
una lluvia de balas mientras las fuerzas
de seguridad trataban de disipar las
manifestaciones más de 120 personas
fueron asesinadas algunos de sus cuerpos
arrojados al nilo mientras los médicos
informaron de decenas de violaciones
cometidas por el personal paramilitar
varios meses después un gobierno civil o
militar tomó el mundo dirigido por el
nuevo primer ministro de sudán abdalá
hand ok encargó un comité de
investigación que descubriera la verdad
sobre los asesinatos de junio con el
objetivo de llevar a los autores ante la
justicia posteriormente se escucharon
las declaraciones de 3.000 testigos
mientras que los miembros del ejército
fueron interrogados en persona pero la
condena retrasó los procedimientos y la
investigación quedó en pausa en octubre
de 2021 el breve atisbo de democracia de
sudán se detuvo cuando los militares
tomaron el poder del gobierno de
transición
andoc fue arrestado junto con otros
funcionarios y el general de mayor rango
del fatal buján tomó el control del país
para corregir el camino de la revolución
decidimos implementar el estado de
emergencia en todo el país el 9 de marzo
de este año las fuerzas de seguridad
allanaron las oficinas del comité de
investigación del 3 de junio sólo dos
días después de que suspendieran todas
sus actividades ahora que el país
conmemora el tercer aniversario de los
asesinatos los manifestantes han vuelto
a salir a la calle para exigir que los
responsables rindan cuentas nos para
continuaremos nuestra lucha y no nos
detendremos tenemos hermanos que
murieron tenemos mártires tenemos
víctimas y no cederemos nuestros
derechos albuja continuaremos nuestra
revolución y si dios quiere ganaremos
mientras tanto la búsqueda de justicia
continúa en sudán
hablemos del cobi 19 la ciudad de
shanghai volvió a ordenar el
confinamiento para cuatro barrios esto
ocurre luego de que la capital
financiera de china atravesará una
cuarentena estricta de dos meses y que
se levantó hace apenas dos días vamos a
beijing donde nuestro corresponsal
adrián foncillas tiene los detalles
algunos en genes es la alegría por el
fin del encierro y por el día del barco
del dragón una festividad que se celebra
bien toda china les ha durado muy poco
las autoridades han detectado nuevos
contagios en la comunidad es decir fuera
de los centros de cuarentena son siete
los primeros en tres días situados en
los distritos de pudong y jingan así que
se ha ordenado otra cuarentena
domiciliaria en cuatro barrios que se
alargará al menos durante dos semanas
además los 26 contactos más cercanos y
los más de 100 contactos secundarios han
sido conducidos a centros de cuarentena
el paso atrás revela la dificultad de
controlar la variante omicron en una
ciudad tan densamente poblada como
shanghai incluso después de un encierro
de más de dos meses fue levantado en la
medianoche del miércoles en muchos
shanghaineses corrieron a la calle a
celebrarlo en algunos casos sin respetar
la distancia social que recomiendan las
autoridades tras la reapertura siguen
los controles es obligatorio un test
cada 72 horas y para engrasar el proceso
se han levantado más de 15.000 puestos
en toda la ciudad vanhanen se sin
embargo lamentaban hoy que han tenido
que soportar largas colas bajo el sol
veraniego en alemania al menos 4 muertos
y 30 heridos dejó el descarrilamiento de
un tren el hecho se produjo en los alpes
bávaros en el sur del país luego de que
un tren regional que iba camino a
mo'nique se saliera de las vías la
policía confirmó que los labores de
rescate continúan y que muchas personas
tuvieron que ser evacuadas por las
ventanas del tren todavía se desconocen
las causas del accidente
hasta aquí las noticias los invitamos a
que sigan conectados con france24
france24 puntocom
[Música]